willkommen bei zdf heute live mit ihrem
live stream zu aktuellen ereignissen am
tag nach den anschlägen von wien gestern
abend gegen 20 uhr erreichte die polizei
in wien mehrere anrufe dass einer oder
mehrere menschen um sich schießen würden
in wiens ersten bezirk dem ausgeführte
mittlerweile wissen wir dass der
anschlag wohl einen islamistischen
hintergrund haben soll oder haben könnte
einer der täter wurde gestern abend
erschossen nach weiteren wird derzeit
gefahndet und die bittere bilanz des
abends vier tote zwei männer und zwei
frauen mindestens 17 verletzte davon
mindestens sieben schwer ein polizist
ist darunter und darüber möchten wir
heute reden mit unserer korrespondentin
britta hilpert in wien und der
politikwissenschaftlerin peter ramsauer
ihre und eure fragen bitte gerne zu dem
thema unten in die vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten oder an zdf heute -
live at zdf.de
dann gibts ne mail hierzu mein studio
und wir schauen was wir davon mit ins
gespräch nehmen können
es gab eine schweigeminute in wien heute
mittag um 12 uhr
die menschen haben der toten gedacht die
ganze stadt steht unter schock und etwas
früher und 10.30 hat österreichs
bundeskanzler sebastian kurz eine
pressekonferenz gegeben eine erklärung
abgegeben und dort hat er unter anderem
dass ihr gesagt
die gestrige nacht wird daher auf
tragische weise in unsere geschichte
eingehen als eine nacht in der einige
unserer mitmenschen einen brutalen
anschlag zum opfer fielen einem anschlag
der in wahrheit uns allen gegolten hat
einem anschlag auf unsere freie
gesellschaft
aber klar ist
wir werden uns von den terroristen nicht
einschüchtern lassen
wir werden unsere grundwerte unserer
lebensmodell und unsere demokratie
mit aller kraft verteidigen wir werden
die täter die hintermänner und deren
gleichgesinnte ausforschen jagen und sie
der gerechten strafe zuführen und wir
werden alle die etwas mit dieser
schandtat zu tun haben mit allen zur
verfügung den mitteln verfolgen
also wird also das statement von
österreichs bundeskanzler sebastian kurz
britta hilpert ist für uns in wien ganz
kurz britta wo stehst du jetzt genau ich
stehe hier am schwedenplatz unweit der
stelle wo die schießerei gestern abend
um 20 uhr begann
wie ist die stimmung in der stadt gerade
was nimmst du war ich habe gehört und
gelesen dass stadt weitgehend zumindest
im innenstadtbezirk quasi nicht betreten
werden darf ist es richtig es ist
tatsächlich so dass die polizei dazu
aufgerufen hat möglichst fern zu bleiben
dem innenstadtbereich es waren auch
teile abgesperrt es sind auch immer noch
teile abgesperrt ich glaube man sieht es
hinter mir die polizei ich werde
insbesondere den weg zu der gasse ab wo
die schießerei begann wo auch die
synagoge der stadt wien sich befindet
man spürt aber auch dass die lage sich
jetzt ein wenig beruhigt es ist zwar
immer noch nicht klar ob wirklich alle
täter von gestern abend gefasst sind
es ist immer noch nicht klar wie viele
täter es überhaupt waren wir wissen ja
dass es einen toten an getöteten
attentäter gibt aber die polizei will
jetzt in wenigen minuten weitere details
zu den vorgängen gestern abend bekannt
geben und vielleicht erfahren wir dann
auch wie viele täter es aber im großen
und ganzen ist es so dass man hier schon
spürt dass weiterhin ermittelt wird auch
tathergänge wir haben hier von einer
halben stunde eine ortsbegehung der
polizei beobachten können wo also
minutiös auch nochmal nachgezeichnet
wurde wer was wo wann wie hier genau am
schwedenplatz passiert ist und eben
nicht nur hier sondern an fünf weiteren
tatorten in der stadt liegen
da können wir vielleicht mal auf die
karte gucken die wir vorbereitet haben
wo wir den tatablauf so gezeigt haben
oder auch vorbereitet haben dass ihr das
jetzt wissen der zeit gehen nämlich die
behörden in österreich davon aus dass
das ganze am schwedenplatz beginn 20 uhr
fallen in der seitenstraße die ersten
schüsse in unmittelbarer nähe zu der
hauptsynagoge von wien in der gegend ist
der schwedenplatz und da kommt es zu
einem schusswechsel zwischen attentäter
und polizei von insgesamt fünf oder
sechs tatorten ist die rede da gehen die
informationen gerade auch noch
auseinander britta hilpert wenn ich da
richtig informiert sind wissen wir wie
viele es jetzt tatsächlich sind wie
viele tatorte es man kann davon ausgehen
dass an insgesamt an insgesamt sechs
orten geschossen wurde das ist zumindest
der jetzige informationsstand ich muss
allerdings auch sagen dass sollte
gestern abend wir berichten ja praktisch
seit gestern abend heute-journal 21.45
ununterbrochen immer mal wieder im zdf
seit gestern abend sich wirklich die
informationslage immer mal wieder
geändert hat das gehört zu einer solchen
unübersichtlichen terrorlager auch dazu
dass der kenntnisstand sich auch immer
erneuert und man auch neue informationen
erlangt also was man mit sicherheit weiß
das sollte man vielleicht auch noch mal
ganz deutlich sagen wir sind gestern
abend vier zivile opfer
diesen terroranschlag zum opfer gefallen
menschen die den letzten abend vor dem
teil lockdown in österreich genießen
wollten oder die hier sogar gearbeitet
haben im fall einer kellnerin ist das
wohl der fall und es sind weitere 14
menschen immer noch in den
krankenhäusern teilweise ringen sie mit
schweren schussverletzungen um ihr leben
das wissen wir mit sicherheit aber wie
gesagt die lage ist noch nicht
vollkommen geklärt und wir erhoffen uns
aus einer pressekonferenz in wenigen
minuten neue erkenntnisse gut bis dahin
hoffen wir dass wir dich nicht all zu
lange binden müssen wir wollen uns mal
kurz angucken ein stück dass uns unser
kollege wolf christian ulrich gemacht
hat über den stand der ermittlungen und
über das was danach passiert ist
dieser terroranschlag trifft wien mitten
ins herz schüsse in einem beliebten
wiener ausgehviertel am letzten abend
vor der ausgangssperre die die heute
gegen korona beginnt vier zivile opfer
sterben bei dem anschlag österreich im
schock es war ein anschlag aus hass aus
hass auf unsere grundwerte aus hass auf
unser lebensmodell aus hass auf unsere
demokratie in der alle menschen am
rechten und würde gleich sind dieses
video soll den attentäter zeigen die
polizei erschießt ihn kurze zeit später
wie sich heute herausstellt ein 20
jähriger anhänger des esr schoss auch
nach einer synagoge die zu jenem
zeitpunkt aber geschlossen war
aktuell fahndet die polizei nach
weiteren beteiligten helfern
hintermännern
die behörden berichten von mehreren
festnahmen wir haben gestern abend einen
anschlag erlebt von mindestens einem
islamistischen terroristen 14
schwerverletzte einige von ihnen
schweben noch in lebensgefahr
ärzte sprechen von schuss und
stichwunden die bürgerinnen und bürger
heute früh angespannt verunsichert
traurig mir geht's so schlecht friedlich
da ich mit meiner familie halt gleich
hier wolle
ist halt natürlich sorge darum meine
frau mein kind
wir sind eigentlich glaube ich alle noch
ein paar arbeiten dass das wirklich in
wien stattgefunden hat die fahndung in
österreich läuft für die behörden ist
die gefahr noch nicht gebannt
so die schau mal kurz in die kommentare
ich musste leider mal wieder ein
bisschen dazu auffordern dass man
bestimmte sachen richtig und entlässt
hetze in jede richtung bringt überhaupt
nichts einen kommentar möchte ich
stellvertretend vorleben lesen von
michael schmidt die schreibt es gibt
keine religion die sich den
terror-anschlägen verschreibt es gibt
aber terroristen die glauben dazu auf
dass alle aus allerschlimmste zu
missbrauchen
britta hilpert in wien was ist dann über
den attentäter bislang bekannt es ist
tatsächlich bekannt dass der getötete
attentäter wohl bis dezember 2009 10
eine gefängnisstrafe verbüßt er war
einschlägig als ihr es sympathisant
bekannt war wohl auch im gefängnis weil
er angab beim sogenannten heiligen krieg
mitwirken zu wollen
die polizei hatte ihn aber nicht
eingeschätzt als jemanden der in solchen
terroranschlag verüben wollte wie gesagt
nicht bekannt ist bisher ob es noch
weitere und die viele mittäter ist noch
gar nicht bekannt ist außerdem welche
art von unterstützung er womöglich noch
hatte es ist jetzt hier am morgen zu
mehreren hausdurchsuchungen gekommen und
auch zu einigen festnahmen nicht nur in
wien sondern auch in städten wie st
pölten und linz wichtig ist aber auch
und das möchte ich ausdrücklich und auch
ungefragt einmal noch mal sagen das
natürlich dieser kommentar den du da
gerade vorgelesen hast auch etwas ist
was hier von der stadt und von der
regierungsspitze betont wird man bemüht
sich sehr darum dieser botschaft des
hasses und der spaltung der von diesem
terroranschlag ausgeht etwas anderes
entgegenzusetzen nämlich eine botschaft
der gemeinsamkeit wörtlich hieß es heute
in der ansprache von sebastian kurz
dieses kein kampf von kulturen dieses
kein kampf von religion sondern dies ist
nur ein kampf von zivilisationen gegen
bar- bereitet vielen dank für diese
eindrücke vom schwedenplatz in wien
wir werden weiter zu dir schalten im
laufenden programm eventuell auch noch
mal live heute abend je nachdem wie sich
die lage entwickelt und sprechen jetzt
sprechen mit peter ramsauer
politikwissenschaftlerin und auch
journalistin hat sich viel beschäftigt
mit dem islam war vielen islamischen
ländern unterwegs und mit der frage der
islamistischen szene habe frau ganz
schön dass sie da sind vielleicht mal
zunächst zu
einen ordner in österreich ist unser
nachbarland aber manche sachen ist man
nicht so gut informiert wie hier in
deutschland wie groß ist die
islamistische szene in österreich ist
die vergleichbar mit in deutschland nun
ja das könnte man schon im weitesten
sinne sagen also ich habe im buch
recherchiert wo ich mich ganz stark auf
diese szene und auch die auswanderer
beschäftigt habe und da gibt es
unterschiede zu deutschen dass wir
hatten circa 300 personen die in den
islamischen staat ausgewandert sind im
vergleich zu deutschland sind das auch
die pro kopf zahlen gerechnet relativ
viele und dann gibt es noch einen großen
unterschied bei uns waren sehr viele von
den auswanderern hatten einen
hintergrund in tschetschenien dass die
hälfte und die andere hälfte und da das
bringt mich ein bisschen zur tat gestern
die hatte offensichtlich hintergrund im
balkan in kosovo und auch in bosnien bis
hin zu noch mazedonien
hier gab es einige moscheen wo man auch
ganz klar erkennen konnte wie wie hier
die verbindung zwischen wien und dem
balkan passiert ist es gibt hier in
deutschland sofort jetzt auch hier diese
islamdebatte wo genau über maschinen
debattiert wird muss man sie schließen
muss man die verbindung zur dz also zur
türkischen religionsbehörde kappen das
gibt's ja auch durchaus schwierige
verbindungen in deutschland wie ist denn
das vorgehen der österreichischen
behörden was das angeht also so eine
sache schleichenden radikalisierung über
bestimmte prediger über bestimmte
moscheen oder bestimmte finanzwege
wunder gab st er ein sehr klares
vorgehen
wie gesagt es gab eine moschee in wien
da gab es eine ganz klar comics auch zu
einer radikalisierten gegend nämlich
wenn man in bosnien und da ist man sehr
sehr stark vorgegangen hat hier auch
einige prediger vor gericht gestellt
allerdings und das zeigt gegen der
islamische staat es ist wahnsinnig
schwierig der einzelnen sympathisant zu
identifizieren anders als die el kaida
gab es daher selten direkten
kommunikation zwischen sympathisanten
und dann beginnen die zum terroranschlag
aufrufen
es kann euch jemand sein die in einer
moschee gewesen ist er sich nicht als
radikal zu erkennen gibt viele
radikalisierung basiert übers internet
und da läuft die kommunikation von
einrichtungen die andere
also ich kann sagt du mir das sehr sehr
schwer zu überprüfen wer sich stark
radikalisiert und das sagen mir auch
sämtliche experten gesagt und ich glaube
das ist gerade jetzt ein wichtiger punkt
auch bewährungshelfern
bewährungshelferin die ja mit ihnen
arbeiten die schon kurze haftstrafen
verbüßen wie ihn mit diesem fall und
dann sehen wie radikalisiert ist diese
person
das lässt sich im fall dieser tee hat
generation die es wahnsinnig schwer
einschätzen
wir haben eine frage hier aus unserer
zuschauerschaft von veronika frais auf
facebook die möchte wissen der junge
mann stand unter beobachtung weil er
wegen terroristischer tätigkeiten davor
schon straffällig geworden das zumindest
war ja schon im gefängnis das heißt man
hätte ja zugriff auf ihn gehabt wir
haben gerade gehört von unserer kollegin
britta hilpert in wien dass man ihn aber
so ein attentat nicht zugemutet hat da
ist dass die frage warum lässt sich da
gar nichts machen ähnliche frage von an
die flure auf oder angie flow auf
facebook warum hat man den laufen lassen
wenn das schon auffällig wurde
woher das ist eine frage für ganz europa
momentan steht wir hatten ja relativ
geringen haftstrafen für jene die nicht
wie es nicht geschafft haben wie sie ist
und nur wegen der versuchten ausreise
oder einer tatsächlichen ausreise vor
gericht gestellt werden da kommen jetzt
sehr viele frei und das ist natürlich
unglaublich schwer für uns jetzt
einzuschätzen wer hat sich in dieser
zeit im gefängnis da gibt's ja
engagierte radikalisierte
radikalisierung programme in österreich
genauso gut auch in anderen europäischen
ländern
wer hat sich da dann tatsächlich die
radikalisieren lassen
wer ist noch immer mit dem islamischen
staat zu gründen und ja so gut auch
diese psychiatrischen verein sicher
arbeiten und auch die bewährungshilfe es
wird immer wieder das problem geben dass
jemand es vertauscht die radikalisiert
worden zu sein und ich denke diese
entsetzliche tage in wien sollte uns
alle noch viel stärker darüber
nachdenken lassen das passiert in den
gefängnissen was können wir in den
gefängnissen tun und vor allem was tun
die medien die dann frei gehen weil es
wird nicht die kapazitäten geben weder
in österreich noch in anderen ländern
diese menschen wirklich rund um die uhr
lückenlos zu bewachen
hat denn da die österreichische
regierung eher so ein ich sag mal
knallhart kurs dass man sagt man geht da
wirklich reinfuhr
die menschen und versucht es über
strafen zu regeln oder gibt es da auch
so eine deeskalationsstrategie dass man
versucht tatsächlich auch die ursache
für dieses verhalten zu finden und
dagegen vorzugehen
da gab es ein ganzes maßnahmenpaket also
ich bei mehreren terrorprozess eine undo
send wegen fälle wie dieser die ausreise
versucht haben verurteilt wurden und da
ging in die österreichischen gerichte
sehr sehr hart vor aber trotzdem dieser
haftstrafen sie wurden verhängt ebenso
in den brenta vergangenen jahr können
aufgrund des deliktes gar nicht länger
ausfallen denn eigentlich haben diese
menschen ja nichts verbrochen
höhere strafen rechtfertigen würde was
es allerdings gibt es sind sehr
intensives programm wo man darauf achtet
was in den gefängnissen passiert
trotzdem höre ich immer wieder dass hier
vielleicht noch nicht genug getan wird
gleichzeitig denke ich mir es ist viel
zu früh hier irgendwelche
verantwortlichen schuldigen zu
identifizieren das was wir aus diesen
vielen entsetzlichen terrorangriffen
doch der ds gelernt haben
nicht nur in österreich jetzt leider
sondern auch in deutschland in
frankreich ist wie unendlich schwierig
es ist hierzu die radikalisieren diese
gruppen unter beobachtung zu halten
bassen notwendig sein wird ist ganz klar
noch einmal darüber nachzudenken das
geschieht in den gefängnissen und da gab
es ja auch die angst dass die
gefängnisse auch radikalisierung punkte
sein könnten
hier bieten dänemark spannende ansätze
ich glaube sollten daher ohne
schuldzuweisungen noch einmal ganz
gezielt darüber nachdenken dass wir dann
noch einbringen können so vor angst aber
ich muss noch mal kurz in unseren chat
gehen da gibt es auf youtube eine
riesige diskussion ob für den netz zu
machen sollen oder schließen
liebe kollegen in der regie schaltet
doch mal auf meinen rechner hier also da
kommt auch von anderen usern die gut
gemeinte bitte leute seid respektvoll
beleidigt nicht rum dann kommt so ein
kommentar von cola light hier wir würden
hier an zdf die diskussion kontrollieren
wollen wir hätten angst vor unangenehmen
ansichten das lieber cola light hier ist
nicht der fall wir haben keine angst vor
unangenehmen ansichten wir haben angst
vor hetze vor beleidigungen das heißt
auch keine angst gedulden die einfach
nicht das gibt's bei uns nicht und
deswegen wenn es zu viel wird das nicht
mehr kontrollieren können dann müssen
wir irgendwann die reißleine ziehen und
wir sehen darunter einen kommentar von
silva
2k dummer idiots und das ist genau der
grund warum wir irgendwann den chat zu
machen
nicht weil wir keine angst weil wir
keine unangenehmen fragen haben wollen
aber keine kritischen fragen sondern
weil wir so was dir nicht dulden ja wer
sich nicht benimmt fliegt raus und wenn
es zu viele werden müssen wir alle
rausschmeißen so dass die ansage hier
aus dem studio von mir frau ramsauer wir
können wieder über fachliche und
sachliche sachen reden
ich schau mal hier auf facebook da gab
es einen statement vor stefan münster
nicht jeder moslem ist ein terrorist
aber jeder terrorist ist ein moslem kann
man das verstehen lassen keinen
umständen wir haben ja gerade in den
vergangenen jahren gesehen dass
rechtsextreme t erwarten zu nehmen und
es gibt viele experten und expertinnen
die sagen im grunde genommen steckt da
dieselbe menschenverachtende fanatismus
dahinter ich würde da dringend davor
warnen hier eine zuordnung zu machen
manchmal hatte ich auch den eindruck
dass china dies muss passieren kult wie
eine wie eine sekte funktioniert und zu
den spannendsten ergebnissen die hier in
österreich gehört habe war dass jene
expertinnen und experten die sich mit 16
kulten aus kranken oft sehr gute erfolge
hatten bei der die radikalisierung ein
weg den ich finde der bringend auch
gegangen werden muss
ich möchte noch etwas dazu sagen gerade
weil ich jetzt diese diese youtube
debatte die sie da vorgetragen haben ein
bisschen höhere worauf der unendlich
achtgeben müssen ist dass wir diesen
attentätern nicht die gelegenheit geben
ihre taten im nachhinein zu einen
kontext zu geben
ich glaube das ist unglaublich
gefährlich hier auf diese debatte
einzusteigen
es geht ihm so genau ich meine ob es
sich um eine islamismus um eine meiner
islamdebatte hat um eine ost gegen west
orient gegen okzident davon profitieren
die reguläre guter und auch gerade von
dieser debatte
ich denke diesen unheimlich achtsam zu
führen damit hier nicht neue tagungs
period werden wenn wir müssen immer
darauf achten dass alles was wir
erzählen dass wir in der tat schildern
auch von ihnen gehört wird die
radikalisiert sind und für mich gehabt
es zu den schockierendsten dingen gehört
im islamischen staat sie haben eine
regelrechte medienmacht aufgebaut wo es
auch eine wöchentliche kolumne
so sehen uns die europäer und da hat man
gerade solche wortmeldungen
richtiggehend zelebriert schaut die die
die charakterisieren was als die wahren
feinde
deshalb waren nicht das wohl hier eine
zu großen theoretischen klammer zu
ziehen sondern es gilt ganz klar dabei
zu sein was ist ein eiskalter
kaltblütiger mord
wir haben ja gerade gehört von meiner
kollegin britta hilpert dass sebastian
kurz der bundeskanzler das versucht hat
zumindest will ich das mal so deuten
indem er eben nicht diesen diese diesem
konflikt auf gemacht hat sondern gesagt
dass city gegen zivilisation gegen und
zivilisiertes handeln ist das so einen
ansatz den sie da befürworten würden
oder geht das noch anders weil ich
versuche das gerade praktisch
vorzustellen
natürlich ist es ein richtiger ansatz
was mir besonders gut gefallen das ist
der aus einer anderen ecke wie die
neuseeländische premierminister kinder
hören reagiert auf die ab montag den
krankenkassen wir nicht den mann nicht
beim namen nennen lassen ihn nicht die
möglichkeit geben ihm eine bietet bin
und ich denke dass ich das hier jetzt
alle angerufen dass wir das hier
abkanzeln hier nicht jemanden sozusagen
auch als attentäter ich ganz langsam
unter anführungszeichen verherrlichen
das halte ich für das allerwichtigste
was im moment an kulturen können sowie
sebastian kurz reagiert stimmt das
natürlich und ist auch sehr hilfreich
und grundansatz nein wir lassen uns
nicht dazu hinreißen einen teil unserer
bevölkerung migranten sei es menschen
die eine andere religion haben dass die
mehrheit der österreicher und
österreicherinnen hier vorzuverurteilen
worum aber geht ist hier ganz klar
diesen menschen die solche attentate
verüben
eben nicht 15 minuten berühmtheit zu
können sondern sich ganz klar auf zu
konzentrieren was in diesem stark dass
in europa funktioniert dann können wir
doch mal zwei männern die 15 minuten rum
unter bühne die sie verdient haben wir
sind gerade gefragt worden auf facebook
von sedat sahin karabulut warum wir
nicht über die zwei türkischen helden
berichten die einen verletzten
polizisten gerettet haben
das haben wir schon getan die beiden
männer kriegen glaube ich gerade sehr
viel aufmerksamkeit verdient ihren namen
möchten wir jetzt nennen
rachel king und michael sind die haben
nämlich gestern einer älteren frau und
einen polizisten auf dem schwedenplatz
geholfen aus der situation
herauszukommen
herr gültekin wurde oder wer bitte kennt
wurde beim helfen angeschossen richtig
also hat sich tatsächlich als jemand
herausgestellt der sich auch in die
bresche schmeißt von daher diesen beiden
männern möchten wir jetzt unsere unseren
dank zollen und auch sagen die haben es
verdient dass er genannt wird der
attentäter möchten wir jetzt erst mal
nicht denn frau kam es aber vielen dank
für das gespräch für ihre händen
einblicke in die österreichische seele
und ich hoffe wir sprechen irgendwann
mal wieder so dann gucke ich noch mal
hier in den chat ich glaube wir haben
erstmal keine weiteren fragen wir werden
natürlich weiter dranbleiben ladet euch
die zdf heute herunter
da kann man dann auf jeden fall immer
informiert bleiben auch wenn gerade kein
lärm machen außerdem gibt's dann immer
einen schönen alarm wenn wir hier live
gehen
und ansonsten nicht erst mal noch einen
entspannten tag und bis bald